le trait quotidien à bientôt des rails
et qui veut rester le temps on n'a qu'à
bien s'accrocher
le train train quotidien va bientôt des
rails et qui veut rester le dornach
amiens 5 rochelais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
et nous
[Musique]
2013 [__] je vois ça quand j'étais
petit lob une impression que l atout sur
la lune ont refusé qu'on a dit ouais ça
va être l'an 2000 le bug est toujours
l'impression que c'était clair 2013 mais
j'ai rencontré benoît delépine au
festival de mons festival du film
d'amour de mons où il venait présenter
michael que le compte à rebours
compagnie assez déprimée on avait passé
la nuit à picoler et c'était la première
fois qu'on se rencontre et lui
connaissait benoît pour le voir tirer un
vieux copain depuis longtemps dont
s'étaient jamais rencontrés
j'avais une idée de film pour dénoncer
la manipulation médiatique pendant les
guerres du golfe etc
mais quand tu te retrouves à madagascar
avec un vrai lion qui peut te poursuit
et qu'on est à 6 dans un angle dans un
pick up et que le fini mais qu'est ce
que c'est que quel est le con cas justin
est bien obligé de tenir retiens c'est
moins fait douter bien obligés d'assumer
que moi je voulais faire du cinéma lamy
pour plus de liberté j'en avais beaucoup
moins un point
[Musique]
débat
on pourrait partir
[Musique]
ça va secouer
et moi c'est vraiment réfléchissant puis
en revoyant les fuites au gem enfin
finie mais où est ce que je me suis
planté puis après j'ai eu une
illumination je me suis dit m'attend le
cinéma c'est pas du tout ce que tu fais
ce que je viens de faire ce que je viens
de faire c'est de la bd quoi c'est
cinéma c'est du mystère c'est pas c'est
pas d'expliquer des choses aux gens
d'essayer de de balancer une théorie
aussi belle soit elle ou de quelque
chose d'engager un engagement si
légitime soit-il tout ça c'est rien
enfin c'est de l'information c'est
enfoncer des portes ouvertes quoi mais
si le cinéma c'est du mystère donc je me
suis complètement planté donc à partir
de ce moment là je n'en peux plus je
pensais pas en refaire a priori j'aurais
certainement pas dû en faire parce que
j'étais carbonisé dans le milieu du
cinéma français après un gadin pareil je
peux dire que pourtant m quand on cite
on s'est vraiment la rencontre avec gus
qui m'a donné envie de passer au cinéma
parce que je suis pas sûr que vous serez
relancer ou tout seul je pense pas
j'avais un tel mauvais mauvais souvenir
parce que même en ayant compris
les réseaux non en échec j'avais pas
envie de me remettre
je vais rencontre à cannes parce que je
me rappellerai toujours le voir passer
comme ça moi je savais ce qu'il faisait
sur hollande et tout ça et lui avait vu
le plein de super donc une émission tu
faisais à l'époque on sait juste
regarder comme ça on se fait un signe
c'était les mots bleus les mots qu'on
dirait que les yeux bien ça tombe bien
le dire mais le fait de de vraiment me
marrer avec gus à écrire des sketches
avec lui à jouer dans des sketches avec
lui a enfin imaginer des choses il ya un
jour nous ont rencontrés régulièrement
vincent tavier tant par les deux ou
trois fois on l'a vu temps en temps puis
on use et y en a eu une idée de film en
rigolant donc pour une moitié pour
déconner puis je pouvais ils nous ont
richier quoi c'est dû bref il savait que
j'avais promu c'est arrivé près de chez
vous avec benoît
rémy andré de quelques années avant
qu'on l'avait fait entre nous un petit
film et donc il me dit ouais si je
refais un jour du cinéma c'est avec toi
c'est comme vous fait qu'il faut faire
du cinéma et tout donc voilà c'est mon
jour des bons par le vivre dans une
d'ivresse mais non lui dans sa tête il y
avait une logique et pendant des années
il y avait de me revoir en dix ans vince
et j'ai une idée de film jeu chaque fois
où je trouvais que c'était trop
télévisuel où c'était une bonne idée de
courts métrages murray en long métrage
s'en tire en longueur puis un jour avec
gus ils sont nés rickli dédale tra et là
je ne sais pas il ya parfois des trucs
comme ça qu'on déclenche des vidéos qui
est ce assez
c'est une bonne idée miri 15 pages de
scénario même pas rire à des buts fille
n'y avait eu ni d eve un voyage aller à
la rencontre de kaurismaki tout ça me
plaisait je disais voleur un souffle là
dedans mais ya pas de scénario donc
comment ce qu'on finance dans une
période où même si ce témoin moins
formaté que maintenant ça l'était déjà
quand même beaucoup et tout d'un coup un
anneau terre amie de notre avocat s'est
montré intéressé par le projet il a mis
150 mille euros cash sur la table au
site assez
rock'n'roll qui m'a dit ouais je le
projet d'acheter une maison puis
finalement je vais plutôt mettre
l'argent sur votre team vaud la france
non non non on pouvait y aller allez-y
alesi a même fait jouer dans le film
c'est lui qui conduit le mobile home qui
les abandonnent au bord de la mer avec
sa femme et ses deux filles si on revoit
le film
cette séquence au bord de la mer dans le
mobil home cell notaires les gens sont
gentils
la mousson
frigos des gentils
quoi
je
et c'est vrai qu'elle cesse à annie
moore qui quand même aussi assez assez
belge à léo les belges se retrouvent
bien et surréalistes comme très souvent
un cadre j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour
la créativité des gens et puis bon il
nous avait gentiment proposé et c'est
vrai que c'était alléchant à ce moment
là de jouer dans le film un petit rôle
c'est une expérience aussi pour les
enfants cette défaite est donc ce
n'était pas non plus un montant très
important mais ça permettait de soin de
faire le film ou de soi qu'on pouvait
pas le faire donc c'est un montant
important à ce moment là sans ou avec ça
faisait naître le projet où vous le
faire échouer
j'ai dit oui ce qui était le début d'une
petite aventure
je crois écrit quarante ou cinquante
pages de scénario on est partis à 10
dans une camionnette
sachant que road movie partait de
picardie en finlande
et puis surtout on avait l'idée de boire
un coup et que aki kaurismaki et donc on
a
en fait le film pour pour ça là tout
était réuni c'est à dire que c'est pour
moi ça revenait à la bonne atmosphère
des choses que je tournais avec groland
petite équipe des jambes bien choisie
par vincent parce que c'est quand même
il un sens qui a choisi hugo le chef op
le linge une ingénieur du son guillaume
alors là si j'avais été assez radical
avec benoît et gus et je redis alors là
stop l'honneur c'est bien un truc c'est
que j'ai envie de casser vos habitudes
de télévision et c'est plus moi on est
plus on a d'énergie au delà de 10 il
faut déjà des gens pour commencer à
s'occuper des gens l'énergique donne ces
quatre personnes ou ces dix personnes et
explose tout donc je pense que c'est ça
qu'il faut d'abord dans ce genre de
projet on s'est rencontrés chez juge
d'application des peines
il est condamné à faire du cinéma
j'ai toujours des emmerdes que chaque
fois que je tourne avec eux altra
premier jour de tournage il débarque
chez moi tous ensemble avec toute
l'équipe tu vois très peu nombreux je
savais pas du tout ce que j'allais faire
tout ce qu'elle est c'est que j'ouvrais
le le bal qu'on avait une matinée pour
tourner ce qu'on devait faire
j'ai dit mais quel est mon texte donc ça
se calme une des caractéristiques des
gus et delépine c'est que te donne une
sorte de feuille de papier écrite à la
main si je me souviens bien
en usant vaguement c'est à peu près seul
nous on verra quand on tournait et j'ai
dit ok puis on a fait beaucoup la fête
la veille ce qu'il faut pas faire ça ils
ont quand même appris de plus soul et la
gueule la veille du premier jour et le
lendemain on s'est retrouvé sur ce
motocross la matinée
première scène de motocross il première
scène avec poelvoorde quand même qu'on
avait réussi à convaincre de venir
première premières scènes qu'on tourne
et on l'a tourné que de dos on a tourné
que son cul pour nos qualités faire au
bout d'une demi heure c'était plié n'en
revenais pas vincent du 10e attend sera
quand même le tourner deux faces quand
même on verra on doit faire un film avec
tout ça on voit même pas sa gueule
maintenant c'est très bien pour moi non
mais c'était qu'elle avait passé un
premier tri et verte et verte champion
du septuple champion du monde
78 les citadis à la guitare de son père
90e 2 et fondante ux entendu vous vous
trompez monsieur vous vous trompez non
mais faut pas et qui peut-être tout ce
que dit pourquoi pas en fait evers il a
été six fois gens comme son père deux
choses soit 90 90 fois championne du
monde le cinéma me subi une histoire du
motocross
alors
le retard aux gens
écoute moi bien c'est pareil
c'est pas parce que tu as permettait des
gens qu'il faudrait à grande gueule
devant mon fils aurélien chose qu'un
gamin de quoi faire et me voilà la
cantine parce que nous on peut à la
cantine on peut aller on peut venir
allaient à venir allaient revenir à
l'air de dire allez on va dire autant
qu'on veut vous galant courant jérémy un
abruti oui maintenant les marines de
manière ridicule dont tu trouveras un
short ridicule et puis après comme il
devait tourner l'après midi ils m'ont
planté à la citadelle et personne pour
me ramener donc j'ai dû rentrer en stop
habillé comme un imbécile
j'ai presque failli payer pour tourner
j'adhère complètement à ce à leur
méthode qui est que les accidents vont
nous provoquer et vont nous faire
découvrir des choses justement très
intéressante au niveau du langage
cinématographique
[Musique]
et on rentre à bruxelles avec
je l'humain un disque seule radio k7 et
c'était sony chanté par mouly dit michel
zink ce truc c'est quoi et tout que je
laissais bulli qui chante ça il fera
il faut dans le film donc la même
journée benoît redécouvrir sony et me
éboulis un vrai coup de foudre
[Musique]
sani
c'était très bizarre pour moi c'est pas
une pré en bulles c'est un peu sans
préliminaires les chantiers devant les
gros mots tard c'était une joie de
[__] géante et sonic je ne dise pas
qu'un drame passionnel mais en fait il
aimait bien eux aussi ont été envoûtés
par par me revois pas bon de t'avoir de
castrats
[Musique]
lb yaourt c'est bon non non mais c'était
même dingue parce qu'on a été pris à
telle ou reine qu'est le festival le
plus up de les états unis fin réservé
aux milliardaires c'est un truc de fou
dans les rocheuses
on a eu un prix à londres la critique
internationale on a eu le prix
d'interprétation encore et où les deux
roues le prix du public en transe
ylvanie non mais c'était un peu d
histoire de fou non non c'était étonnant
pour un petit film quand même c'est un
petit film on n'avait aucune pression
[Musique]
une peur mina bar nulle part donc on
était sûr de passer puisque les pas de
bar
[Musique]
donc ça nous avait tellement plus de
faire ce voyage et ce film qu on s'est
dit on va en faire un deuxième
c'est comme des chips en une fois qu'on
a mangé
excusez moi cette image c'est pas un
hasard non plus si dans nos dans nos
films on a parlé d'art brut et de punk
etc
enfin ça soit les les les artistes brut
ou les où les punks c'était à la limite
des gens qui savaient qu'ils savaient
pas dessiner ou qu'ils savaient pas
faire de musique mais qui en faisait
quand même quoi un bon maintenant on va
dire qu'on sait pas faire de cinéma mais
comment on fait quand même est une
espèce de liberté dans dans la phase de
re façons de faire dans laquelle on est
saine fabre se reconnaît
[Musique]
e
l'absolu film c'est l'âge d'or et je
pleurais c'est le seul film que je
revois les ultimes je les revois jamais
je revois jamais un film qu un film que
je revois c'est l'âge d'or tous les ans
mais parce que je trouve que la limite
on aurait pu dû arrêter de faire du
cinéma après celui-là malheureusement
souviens très bien quand ils ont eu
l'idée c'était un festival qui s'appelle
telluride dans le colorado ont gavé
arrabal on a revu
un film de arrabal ils sont et puis pouf
l'idée a surgi de là je n'ai jamais été
acteur et voilà qu'on me donne la
possibilité d'être est un pur avec des
vernets et de l'épiné et je réussis va
pouvoir tourner un brio s'oppose à être
à l'hôtel des poètes
il faut dire qu'ils sont des poètes
qu'avait l'été langue qui plaît et qui
purge ce titre parce qu'il aurait il sa
fiancée merveilleuse et il a les tombes
de l'armée cet essai ils doivent
remercier les vieux pont et qui pis est
tous les deux ils sont les bonheurs
déboires et pas de voir
mais ce qui m'a non il voir à
astronomiquement il va vous ici je
presse est toujours les sévices ou
leiris lytham il voit beaucoup de zones
je vous rappelle que mes parents ont
acheté la vie catholique et qui avaient
des
une représentation de peinture dans la
vie catholique tout du tout les semaines
et que je découpais cette peinture et je
gardais toutes les peintures que je
refaisais en dessin c'est vrai que ces
cadres qu'on fait parce que ce sont des
plans fixes on essaie de bien les
composés et une composition de cadres
effectivement ça peut être une
composition de tableaux et ça doit
l'être parce que c'est important on
pourra videur n'ai pris un format carré
enfin bon on en a nous le cinéma c'est
aussi tenter des choses quoi le maximum
de choses alors on est toujours sur la
plus sur la corde raide mais on va pas
mettre des pantoufles pour faire du
cinéma donc
[Musique]
s'engueulent jamais on s'engueule une
fois par tournage avec la cvt sinon
c'était parce que je il était en train
d'expliquer le film à kassovitz mais
comme le pitch de david haye très
compliqué il s'emmêlait les pinceaux et
moi je lui ai dit non non non non c'est
pas ça tu sais je voulais rattraper le
coup en essayant de clarifier la
situation parce que kassovitz était
notre seule possibilité de faire le fuji
non non c'est pas ça puis jeu mais j'ai
dû le dire un peu vivement hélas il n'a
pas du tout apprécié donc conséquemment
engueuler mais gravement toit en venir
aux mains mais devant kassovitz pendant
notre présentation du projet quoi ils
étaient halluciné y regarder partout
comme ça dans la pièce on comprenait pas
puis après moi je me suis barré aux
chiottes puis quand je suis revenue
glisse était partie puisqu'il doit aller
va te faire [__] avec ton fric à
kassovitz quoi donc le lendemain tu tous
les deux là on est on avait picolé quand
même donc le lendemain on était tous les
deux comme ça quoi puis on a fait moi je
rappelle qu'à sauter dessus et envoie un
sms non désolé pour hier on n'a pas
encore complètement fini notre scénario
du film on en voit un truc
oui encore bravo et yar pour votre
caméra invisible nom était vraiment
persuadé que c'était une canne est
invisible et c'est grâce à castres c'est
vraiment lui qui a vraiment flashé sur
le scénario c'est le seul à nous avoir
dit ne changeait pas une ligne c'est
magnifique
alors tout le monde nous disait pas
écrivait d'abord un scénario après on
verra donc c'est quand même de deux
façons de voir différents et donc c'est
vraiment grâce à lui qu'on a pu le faire
ce film
il a été assez cinglé pour taper du
poing sur la table à canal en disant si
vous faites pas cela vous aurez plus un
seul de mes films face à la personne qui
est capable de faire un truc comme ça
aujourd'hui
moi la scène qui m'a le plus ému de ce
qu'on a fait c'est quand toi tu joues
avec david un handicapé qui a disparu
depuis d'alors mais c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique c'est une scène d'amour
magnifique quand ils te regardent comme
ça c'est fou peut-être passé il nous a
donné ça quoi
et c'est sur la poussée sur la pellicule
je veux dire sa beauté elle est sur la
pellicule de son âme elle sur la
pellicule mais une énorme et lui il est
toujours eu des airs on peut encore le
voir les magnifiques robes on ne sait
pas du surréalisme au sens et pas
n'importe quoi c'est une histoire
vraiment cohérente du début à la fin en
tout cas dans nos têtes mais le fait
d'avoir joué les lips à ce moment là
souvent les l'on peut s'y perdre assez
vite et on s'y perd il vaut mieux avoir
fumé quelque chose pour le regarder quoi
moi qui qui qui se traitent souvent du
leur mieux avant un tournage de bus et
de noix que vont n'importe quel autre
film je dors bien scellée sur le
tournage j'ai pas parce que c'est le
seul tournage où j'ai pas peur quand je
vais chez eux c'est tout même chose à et
appelle un boulet un saint benoît
ce que tu serais libre mois de juillet
on a un petit train voire toile au zoo
de vincennes donana wordsworth outils
bas et scénarios et les potes scénario
et puis arrivé là-bas bon en fait teaser
et écrivent ton texte dit quoi donc moi
j'étais j'arrive au genou de maubeuge
est votre scénario et je crois qu'il
veut de dix pages de trucs que j'ai pas
lu et il m'a expliqué l'histoire et puis
j'avais
trois heures et haché entre deux girafes
exprimant texte bonjour ça va hein bien
logés bien nourrie je suis le
propriétaire du zoo c'est bonjour là
bonjour à ma femme à mes enfants
vous êtes earth est costaud 1
mais on m'a dit que j'en avais la hausse
ils m'ont dit les autres pour tous vos
diplômes c'est impressionnant bon alors
moi évidemment au début j'ai pas
vraiment un travail et ce plus de
travail de basse après un travail
directement lié à vos compétences tout
ça parce que je dis toujours c'est c'est
un début après rien ne vous empêche de
vous êtes volontaire et travailleur de
gravir les échelons et de la hiérarchie
père m'en donner c'est pas moi de venir
aux huit ans dont neuf ans qu'ils
s'aimaient de devenir chef chef par
exemple ça peut ça s'est décidé de
travailleurs et volontaire je dis pas
que je suis pas content
ce que tout jeune venait prendre mes
fonctions j'ai un coup de fil
bonjour c'est benoît delépine on
voudrait faire un film dans un zoo moi
je dis ok ce serait vraiment bien
allez-vous il voulait un zoo un peu
qu'il fasse un peu un peu pourri qui
puisse faire petit ou privés sans grands
moyens donc l'avait pas dit tout de
suite aux côtés phone comme lui
cherchent à zoé plus je pense aux autres
ça m'a fait plaisir
et après quand j'ai su qu'ils voulaient
un zoo qu'il fasse un peu vieillot il
avait raison le zoo et egidio à l'époque
c'est pour ça qu'on est content de le
voir aujourd'hui beaucoup plus rénové
mais il voulait encore ce zoo qui face
aux urbains zoo de l'enfance
je photographie beaucoup d'anus dizaine
morisod à la demande de benoît et de gus
qui avait besoin d'un répertoire d'anus
reposer à caussade rôle donc on avait
fait le tour du parc pour essayer
d'avoir des bonnes photos d'un juge bien
fait mais pas facile à faire je me mens
même sur certains cadavres d'animaux qui
était au congélateur et les plots qu'on
avait pas avait pas sorti quelques-uns
pour les photographier tranquillement
oui
nous
nommé chef tondre et l'autruche notre
bon choix c'est bien l'autriche on peut
pas faire abstraction de cette pression
qui a de partout avec dix-sept films qui
sortent par semaine lamine cissé ne pas
exister quoi enfin quand un film
n'existe pas qu'en face il incita unis
ni des bonnes critiques ni en est un des
festivals n'est ni du public c'est comme
un coup d'épée dans l'eau ça fait ça
fait mal au coeur quand même donc faut
quand même essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il est son existence mais je me
souviendrai toujours david a on a
vraiment c'était catastrophique les
entraîneurs distributrice avec sandra
s'arracher les cheveux le voyez les
chiffres qui tombent et c'était
n'importe quoi quoi trois entrées dans
tel cinéma 10 nantais l'autre et non
était mort dorée donc picoler du
champagne c'est super content n'était
avec josé bové on était tous contents
avait passé une très bonne soirée très
bon souvenir
on
[Musique]
tu n'es dans un petit village près de 50
ha en picardie qui s'appelle le nom
papa était agriculteur et ma maman était
une bonne maman sans emploi mon hobby
enfin mon suppression peut appeler ça du
sport de haut niveau mais je tire à
l'arc et donc demain j'ai une
compétition j'ai le championnat de
charente
donc là je suis en train de préparer mes
flèches une par une pour essayer de
taper dans le mille le plus souvent
possible
on arrive à aller plus vite que d'autres
fall alors on est comme un espèce de
noyaux atomiques espèce de droit tomic
est en perpétuelle
google mans après sur les caractères moi
je suis peut-être plus volontaire est
lui plus exigeants benoît est beaucoup
plus sur l'image
gus est beaucoup plus sur le fait que
les gens jouent juste le fait de prendre
tel
figurant ou tel passant plutôt que le
comédien qui a été prévu pour ça est
bien beau regard sur sur les personnages
et donc du coup sûr sur les comédiens
potentiel annoncé christophe kervern
avec un particularité qui m'a souvent
fait chier c'est que fait comme chainel
et maurice du vieux breton je me suis
pas fait partie des bretons qui ont la
barre de fractions cecab bardot fraction
bng a géré des sa fin une étoile
incroyable j'y pense souvent ça parce
que j'aurais pu très bien tourner un
clochard je pense toujours rien mais et
j'ai eu à chaque fois j'ai su rebondir
dans un truc ou plutôt j'ai eu de la
chance de chaque fois 2 avec quelques
périodes de chômage mais de raccrocher
les wagons et plutôt avec des gens
intéressants à chaque fois
[Musique]
sur un tournage par exemple moi je suis
un peu plus en back office est lui
plutôt devant c'est plutôt lui qui parle
qui donne les indications je lui glisse
un mot dans l'oreille je regarde un peu
derrière mais au final c'est vrai qu'on
veut dire qu'on fait un mort et 50 50 ce
qui est bien heureusement parce que ça
tiendrait pas d'imaginer un mec qui
faisait sens pensons et l'autre 0 ça se
verrait au bout d'un an donc moi je dis
action et lui dit coupez donc c'est ça
c'est vite vu
non mais c'est ça oui c'est mal à louise
mais à nouveau l'idée
je m'adapte encore pire
l'obscurité et dans l'humilité
j'avais plus de munitions avait plus de
fusil et même plus de poignard
j'ai tué en allemand avec mon père au
nez arraché par un éclat d'obus
maintenant je rigole mme à l'époque
c'est par simple j'aimerais pu roder
à la guerre mais c'est une belle
saloperie masse est une bonne école
on apprend beaucoup
c'est pas comme aujourd'hui
de l'hôpital
e
et
j'aimerais bien s'arrêter l'or noir
et moi appelé de téléphonie était
contente qu'il m'appelle parce que
j'avais déjà vu altra je me dis tiens ça
me plaît puis à noter boire un café
ensemble et on a tout de suite bien
accroché visitez aussi maladroitement
j'aime bien les films qui font parce que
l espèce de provocation douce comme ça
le regard qui est qui et souvent même un
peu triste tout le monde et en même
temps ils sont amusé
les tendres ils sont instinctifs ils
sont soit disant bordélique infatti
savent bien où ils vont c'est une espèce
de robes et les joyeuses quand même
s'est fait quand même du bien
au début c est ce qu ils vont parler
tout de suite de ça mais pour que face à
un mec ça m'a perturbé
parce que sinon j'aimerais plutôt bien
les stocks que ce sans excès
au départ je voyais pas pourquoi je
comprenais pas pourquoi
voilà après je comprends pas ce que
c'est ça va encore plus flou d'un
scénario de deux peut-être usurpé son
identité pour avoir du boulot tout le
saint fort en fait
mettre une crédibilité la donne justesse
quand même de belles scènes proposées
tout le moment le début qu'on avait fait
avec les ouvrières j'adorais ça on se
laisse emporter avec une aussi puis
quand le rire via des gens parce qu on
est ému il ya de ce côté là je suis je
[Musique]
l'effet temps
c'est le seul
une
[Musique]
à
c'était quand même près montois toujours
ce film louise michel qui vous poursuit
parce que en effet moi quand celle des
patrons voyous mais c'est vrai on a la
gueule on y va on est tellement petit
louis j'étais que figurante jeter ouvrir
à savoir que dans la ville ouvrière ne
sont pas des figurantes
sinon les patrons n'en serait pas là
sélection des figures est vrai pas tant
de blé
[Musique]
mais la salle
c'est à dire qu'il avait ce côté
convivial à la même famille ouais savoir
c'est vrai que bus et benoît on se met
vraiment à la portée des gens et côtoie
aussi je pense à travers leurs films
dans une population qui n'est pas guindé
qui n'est pas c'est tout à fait ce
qu'ils recherchent de toute façon sinon
on n'aurait pas le succès qui sort
aujourd'hui tu sentais qu'il y avait une
grosse précarité la sucrière du coin qui
étaient pour la plupart d'ailleurs au
chômage et il y avait mis en avait une
qui était hyper timmins elle qui rougit
dans nos amis
quel que sa fille avait la regarder
d'une autre manière parce que sa mère
avait participé à un film donc et c'est
ça m'a toujours remarqué jeu pour moi
c'est aussi important de faire le film
ça m'a permis de sortir de ma coquille
qu'ils ont bien vu que peut faire autre
chose que d'être maire de même au foyer
que toujours faire la même chose en
france on en a marre et puis c'est une
expérience vraiment qu'on a bien que
j'ai bien vécu
et puis ça m'a sorti devant moins
ordinaire et puis ça m'a fait du bien
moralement tout seul c'est par là
permettent d'autre chose que c'est
peut-être ça aussi je pense qu'il n'y a
plus on était tous pareils nous a pas
jugé n'était tous pareils tonnes autant
ils vont attendre de quelqu'un qui est
nombreux et ce n'est que ça fait partie
quand même deux lors de leur film mais
vous laisser partir en sachant qu'ils
sont pas des professionnels autant que
du professionnel il attendre un résultat
qui ne soit pas professionnel c'est ça
qui est paradoxal c'est à dire que du
non professionnels ils vont les emmerder
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient quelque chose
qui soit acceptable et d'une
professionnelle et vous
il faut qu'on arrive à retrouver espèce
de web puisque de non jeu du problème du
nombre impressionnant
donc c'est un peu le mélange des deux
qui fait le choc ce qui donne souvent
lorsque le charme de leur film et
parfois ce qui les rend encore
extrêmement intéressant et riche c'est
qu'ils ne savent pas exactement ce
qu'ils veulent mais vous y aller petit à
petit et y va avec une herse sur louise
michel était venu me voir parce qu'on
s'occupait énormément des noms acteurs
on va dire et à chaque fois qu'il
faisait un truc les nains acteurs ont
crié au génie on applaudissait
puis on disait jamais rien quoi parce
que pour nous c'était
vigilance donc et oubliez moi est venu
me voir en disant les gars je suis pas
bien donnez moi des retours des trucs
qu'est ce que je fais c'est bien hélas
chaque fois pour pour rigoler en des qui
faisait le moindre truc qu'on
applaudisse est génial cgt plus les airs
sonné c'était celui qui a été le plus
dur pour moi c'est louis michel si je
comprenais pas toujours en ald
[Musique]
e
non je sais pas j'ai vu ce nom gibus et
peut-être quand même pas toujours tout
non plus ne peut pas tout expliquer tout
le temps abandonné c'est bien de laisser
le temps et d'expliquer je lui met des
lunettes noires
est ce que benoît les premiers mots jeux
aiguë je suis pas pourquoi donc ta crème
de mecs hyper statique dans le fond tu
sens que tu internet à celle qui
sauverait qui te regardes et tu vois
rien tu vois pas les yeux aura comédien
c'est un peu fragile quand même tu vois
on parfois qu'il dit bon on serait
peut-être qui comme quoi qu'est-ce qui
se passe et puis être sur la distance
des ceintures vachement loin ouais je
suis pas donc une fois que tu as compris
ça après ses bons messages des compris
pendant louise michel
[Musique]
on invente
mais pourquoi ne sont pas parfaits on
pousse à relever les autocars mais ça
mouvement
louise michel ça parle d'un truc touche
tout le monde à ce moment là c'était
quand même au moment où toutes les
banques ont foiré
tout le monde s'est senti lésé donc le
film tombe et la flore le net pour faire
ça à vide à ce n'était plus toi c'est
plus lié à quelque chose va de moins
grand public tu vois c'est plus en
référence un surréalisme à bunuel et
c'est donc ça pouvait moi tout ça ne
pouvait que moi touchés et altra ça
parlait pas de quelque chose qui était
proche des aides de l'inquiétude des
gens donc à partir de louise-michel je
trouve que là il touche en plus quelque
chose qui est très c'est pour ça aussi
que ça c'est au werder un grand public
on met beaucoup de nos tripes quand même
dans un film ne sait pas on déconne et
tout ça mais on est quand même des
choses qui nous révolte qui nous
exaspère qui nous font mal et on essaye
d'en parler donc
donc on s'est quand même à base de tout
ça il ya une grande sensibilité aux
choses aux gens aux malheurs et on
essaye de faire un mix de tout ça avec
de l'humour mais comment ça correspond
plus à nos caractères aussi à notre
énorme sensibilité
[Musique]
sont en harmonie avec ce qu'ils sont eux
dans la vie comment ils font c'est
cohérent et ça marche vraiment une
cohérence je pense pas que c'est des
optimistes
[Musique]
en est l'antithèse des films storyboardé
par exemple on a repéré quand même des
lieux à l'avancé on a repéré par exemple
je sais pas on a repéré une maison ou un
non c'est pas on ne pense à la place de
la caméra qu'au moment où on va tourner
et on y pense pas pendant les repérages
une fois qu'on a choisi de l'endroit on
arrive au moment du tournage le matin
mais on ne sait pas du tout où enfin on
est là on est à la recherche à temps là
là ça serait bien pour telle raison
parce qu'il ya une idée supplémentaire
il ya sa fin on en avait vraiment prévu
sur mammouth on a vraiment prévu et
organisé toute une journée de tournage
dans une usine ou mammuth débouler dans
une usine mais pendant qu'il y avait une
grève avec les syndicalistes les
ouvriers machin dans le c'était un gros
bordel avec des figures on est tous mais
quelque part ça faisait
ben on faisait un peu trop frontal
toujours le syndrome mais que cela se
faisait un peu enfoncer une porte
ouverte fin bref enfin la veille ou
l'avant-veille on se dit mais attend on
n'a pas arrêté de tourner ce qu'on avait
prévu de tourner mais depardieu tout
seul et on est là on voit toute la
journée il est fascinant on écoute on le
regarde on laisser un ordre il est
magnifique il est c'est un lion non là
pas lui tout simplement en quoi tout
simplement en silence on attend quoi
donc on a on a viré toute cette journée
de tournage et on a passé sans en avait
rien de prévu montréal gérard
aujourd'hui on te tournes en rond peut
donc bah si toi sur le talus intox sur
le talus et film on avait la chance
d'avoir un acteur qui lui a besoin d'
absolument rien dire pour qui a une
puissance intérieure tellement folle qu'
il n'y a pas besoin de le faire parler
ah c'est ça la liberté c'est ça c'est de
pouvoir avoir la liberté de dire ben on
à en annuler on fait autre chose cette
chose là bas on sent à ce moment-là du
tournage que c'est important
alors que si tu as un un film vraiment
avec des gros moyens beaucoup de
beaucoup de lumière etc
une fois que celle-ci calais c'est foutu
les schémas [__]
[Musique]
ouais je suis très très forte pour colas
pourrait sans nul autre qu on ne sait
même pas tu dis la porte est ouverte
s'il adore lui faire un film les
plaisirs ça fait plaisir de leur rendre
service
guité bien et supplée gars pendant un
mois et demi de moindres ils ont plus
voulu manger de grippe a ils ont été
dégoûtés à vivre car il refait synphot
la chaîne et cinq fois ils ont ils en
mangent et déçu alors c'était un
ras-le-bol déchets on ne se connaît pas
bien et je sais vous êtes un homme de
valeur en disant que nous nous a
toujours effectué votre travail votre
histoire ça en effet aux statistiques ce
remarquable chez mais ressortent jamais
malade j'avais grognon
[Musique]
les triades ont admis les tirages à
billère c'était vraiment la fête pour
tout le monde et tout le monde était
ravi et on est tombé sur des
professionnels qui étaient québécomm
nouvelle ou pas le melon on était là
vraiment entre amis pour nous c'est
encore dans la tête et à vie
[Musique]
mais quand vous le regardez de trois
fois c'est un grand film mais il ya des
scènes où il y en a qui devraient se
rappeler c'est la vérité et c'est
vraiment dit dans la dans la sincérité
dans dans l'esprit baignoire et carven
c'est leur manière d'exprimer la vérité
est simplement simplement
[Musique]
s'ils ont besoin de moi pour plaisir
découvrir des gens comme ça et avoir des
amis comme ça car ils ont besoin de moi
je vais bientôt la retraite j'irai faire
de tous les films ça ne savait cupra
vous irez faire la cuisine avec gérer à
la fois des dégustations charcuterie et
avec du bon vin ça c'est du tout bon
la partie c'est mon métier
une belle couleur de la peau et du
roseau pour bonne texture un peu
fibreuse barinas dalo elle doit être
fumé au bois d'apple route ou à l'ail
corrige me trompe non je sais pas je
préfère un master en jambes on l'a eu du
temps libre en ce moment voir à pas du
tout c'est plein de choses à faire
non mais je pense que vous avez l'amour
du travail bien créé au smig l'amour du
travail bien c'est au sommaire on va
soyez polis monsieur suis poli je
t'emmerde qu'on a autre chose travailler
le jambon on s'intéresse au moins ce
qu'on fait je passerais bien ta petite
gueule du second foot y soit celui ci
réclame à sa femme on voit la gueule de
tatihou qu'afin de ce kit afin de
connaître la tacc à venir faire un tour
sur la faune à ranger ta gueule toi avec
ta caisse qu'a connue à voilà c'est pas
un gros connard connard ouais t'as
facile à dire via la gare
les gamins
et ta casquette connard ce que j'aimais
beaucoup c'était 7 ce côté un peu
anarchiste et puissent écouter savais
pas si c'était un autre belge et anar
mais il y avait un côté dada comme
d'autres buchens dit j'ai pas fait j'ai
papin 47 toile j'ai eu 40 cette idée et
il y avait ce côté là c'est eux et
qu'ils ont toujours d'ailleurs
je pense que c'est des idées qu'il est
qu'il est ce qui les emporte
et je pense que l'idée de mammouth était
une idée extraordinaire mais plus que
l'idée c'est la façon de tourner c'est à
dire que le tournage devenait
d'agréablement une oeuvre d'art ce
devrait d'ailleurs être de dos qu'ils
aient aussi imaginer 7,7 tignasse et
puis ce verbe qui disparaît dans le
monde du travail et ça m'a fait penser à
mon père qui sitôt qu'on savait des
liens écrit acquis qu'il n'avait plus
rien on lui disait de mon bain tu sais
pourquoi tu sais pourquoi je t'ai pas
donnée qui peut basculer comme ça ça me
plaisait pas ce qu'il y'a rien à dire
c'est là où ça on s'aperçoit que ce soit
des frais créateur parce que la plupart
des gens font 50 prise est finalement
ils en font pas comme dirait bien là à
part eux c'est pas qui s'est pas trouvé
de liberté comme eux ils ont la liberté
de truffes aux la liberté de bertrand
cantat fait des vagues
benoît est un peu je dirais presque
l'aristocrate du site âge dirais que
c'est plutôt ça serait plutôt d'un
philosophe grec qui est qu'il ne sait
pas d'espèces de socrate qu'on
laisserait vivre il devient un igloo un
hérisson iris au douloureux avait des
epide qui ne pique pas d'ailleurs une 13
e r d il a des puces est bourré de puces
mais c'est ça est très très dur à vivre
et donc qu'ils aient pu partager ces
moments avec eux ils étaient commis sans
quoi c'est à dire des poètes rien à dire
rien à dire à ça
[Musique]
envoyé à le vérifier mais bon qu'est ce
qui ne l'est pas et c'est ce à quoi bon
nous on est ouvert à tous donc mais en
fait c'est juste que c'est depardieu qui
lui peint c'est le sexe quoi donc
gérard est assez taquin et en plus c'est
drôle parce qu'il fut sûr qu'il ya des
acteurs qui auraient même refusé de
faire un truc pareil lui dès que c'est
pas banal il forme ce soir
donc s'il est quand même extraordinaire
d'avoir un acteur pas il y en a
tellement qui ciblent le beauf à qui
l'aurait jamais fait
quand on est sur un tournage on est
toujours très très à l'affût on regarde
beaucoup mieux les choses les gens les
animaux leur beauté leur beauté
intérieure lors on est toujours annoncée
comme ça qu'on est tombé sur des gens
extraordinaires aussi un comme miss ming
par exemple c'est parce que les elle
était apparue mais en tant que poète s
qui avait rien à voir avec le film en
train de déclamer des poèmes sur la
plage bas dans le nord pendant qu'on
tournait à vide a cédé rencontre dans le
temps on était tellement plaque sensible
quand tu es sur un tournage c'est une
véritable plaque sensible on l'a repéré
comme ça alors que peut-être que si on
l'avait rencontrée dans la réalité on
soit là qu'est ce que c'est que cette
dingue je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
là on a vu sa beauté quoi donc du coup
on la fait tourner sur louise michel
mammouth enfin ce sont surtout les films
depuis
[Musique]
les papillons tant de chansons entre 6
et 11 ans
[Musique]
cette chanson c'est une dédicace pour
leur coeur et pour tout ce qu'ils font
pour les gens et et heureusement qu'on
les a comme des réalisateurs du du 21e
siècle
benoît et gus ils m'ont donné ma chance
de but et un patron dans louise michel
donc après ils m'ont donné notre chance
dans dans mammuth où j'ai fait une
artiste qui faisait des poupées qu'elle
était la nièce de serge pilardosse et
avoir tout pommes de terre j'ai un
cadeau pour toi fermés yeux ouvre tes
yeux regarde c'est toi
un géant l'extérieur et tout doux à
l'intérieur l'éléphant c'est ton coeur
lapin ce sont tes mains et le ouistiti
sait-on zizi oui c'est bien fait pour
toi
c'est vraiment beau parce que de donner
de la chance aux gens qui n'ont pas de
de talent si ce père beau et la famille
c'est toujours la même et il donne
toujours une chance pour qu'un nouveau
membre arrive même quelqu'un qui
croisent dans la rue mais y montre que
ce sont des gens qui qui donne de
l'amour et pas par que par leur
technique et c'est pour ça que le cinéma
de gustave et benoît je crois que c'est
une révélation de notre siècle
ça c'est à dire je vous aime et je vous
remercie
comme disait depardieu après avoir fait
mammouth disait vous m'avez réenchanter
nous pareil il faut on serait enchante à
chaque fois parce que sinon on n'arrive
pas à faire les choses en mécaniquement
mais on n'y arrive pas
[Musique]
le grand soir dès le départ ils m'ont
parlé western et donc moi j'ai vu une
tripotée de western
donc voilà les plans western ils sont un
peu en contre-plongée évidemment le
scope les lieux communs sont ceux
directement tirée des môles américains
qui eux mêmes ont cette géométrie d'un
de la rue unis que les les magasins de
chaque côté des saloons elle côté
western qui vient tout de suite en tête
quand on se balade dans ce genre de lieu
puis on a essayé justement de forcer un
peu le trait dans certains plans on en
faire trop non plus mais entre ça et de
l'harmonica de deux bâches ou mbassa nul
suffisait aux femmes dans le cinéma de
benoît et gus il n'y a pas d'entrée de
chant ya pas de sortie de champ il n'y a
pas de raccordant lac sauf si c'est
nécessaire
ou bien comprendre la situation il n'y a
pas de champ contre champ c'est-à-dire
que dans un cadre on a toujours essayé
de raconter le l'essentiel du propos de
la séquence bonjour je me suis mis
on m'a chargé de vous dire que vos deux
fils ouais ça va pas quoi ça va pas
bailly ils vont pas ils vont pas non pas
ça sera bon mais ça va aller
ah non ça va pas aller ils vont plus ils
vont plus du tout ou alors ça va mais ça
ça va mal aller et ça va ah oui c'est ça
va ça va pas du tout ça mais vous allez
oui oui je vais vous avez vraiment je
vais pas leur dire que ça va les
salariés chabalier je vais à gond
malgré tous les efforts qu'il faut pour
donner l'impression qu'ils sont les gens
foutres ils ont qu'à un message à
délivrer ce qui peut être dangereux ce
qui peut être très ennuyeux donc il
reste quand même un monsieur dans une
catégorie du film social mais
sophistiqué donc c'est pas des cochons
c'est pour ça que les gens qui
travaillent avec eux ne sont pas des
cochons on est des gens et joyeux ça je
crois que c'est le nom qui leur aura le
mieux sont joyeux c'est des gens joyeux
ces gens et même quand ils sortent
déprimée parce que dieu c'est scier
parfois ils sont des moments de blues
ils ont l'élégance de rester joyeux que
ça chante ça casse et ce grâce à fait
chez tout le monde
il ya des normes à respecter aujourd'hui
mais pau moyen-âge alors on critique aux
critiques
n'empêche que c'est par hasard si
l'espérance de vie augmente et wifi dans
la rue tous les jours alors il faut
chercher j'en ai jamais vu une espérance
de vie ici rate je le connais ton
discours je présume que tout ça pour toi
c'est l'ennemi la nôtre puisque
l'attaqué des milliers de gens qui
viennent ici tous les jours
justement parce que c'est moins cher
parce qu'il ya de la vie la vie du froid
l'été de la chaleur l'hiver là c'est
qu'ils ont été tout la crise un des
rares endroits au monde où tu peux te
problème les bâtiments aux normes avec
des gens aux normes entouré produit au
niveau de la connerie n'est pas aux
normes
les gens sont absurdes situations sont
absurdes portée au paroxysme et les gens
sont fous la situation est folle mais
ils vont pas aller la travestir par la
caméra il pose la caméra il dans ce
décor tel qu'il est ils prennent
vraiment il faut un grand écart entre
entre réalité et du relais la caméra
n'est pas un outil de captation c'est un
outil d'expression chez eux
c'est après tout une bravache qu'ils
expriment
on s'en fout on tourne très peu machin
c'est pas vrai une vraie réflexion
d'écriture il ya une vraie réflexion de
encore une fois de caméras il ya un
casting et chiadé ils écrivent pour des
gens il pense à des gens quand ils
écrivent
ben tu vois donc c'est c'est un fou
dépouillement c'est un fou amateurisme
ils cherchent des complices j'ai eu des
complices n'y a pas de calcul chez eux
c'est l'art de faire de faire un propos
lourds avec des instruments léger
lardeux d'être très dérangeant d'être
très perturbant d'être très incisif avec
trois fois rien aux matériels n'ont pas
besoin de faire des explosions avec
quatorze caméras et ses atouts mais ils
le font très simplement
[Musique]
c'est un type qui de 3 vraiment à fond
tentative de suicide pour par pendaison
ce que j'ignorais complètement je suis
pas sûr qu'ils ignoraient c'est
peut-être une des réseaux même de ce
casting je parle peu à peu avec le mec
simple et christian et qui me dit 20
patois local à ces nouveaux que trois
ans avant il a fait pareil et quand je
lui parle
ces défis la chair de poule il sera
entendu trois ans avant il ne faut
surtout pas lui pas les leurs à un
moment donné dans ce petit k o se joue
là sur ce bout de route on tournait je
me retourne je vois tu christian ils l
ont déjà en place de l'autre côté
sous le hangar et je me rappelle il est
allé précipitant il ya tous les coups il
s'est pendu et ses bouffées d'angoissé
tu vois je me suis précipité en fait ils
étaient pas il attendait la crise mais
j'ai vraiment cru que c'était pendu
bonjour je viens vous dire austère on
était en en étant fédé qui en a une
une panne de gaz il y aurait vraiment du
gazeau le nom
vous savez il ya des moments où on est
on est on est pas très en forme
on a l'impression que ça va très mal
mais c'est juste une valeur c'est ça
c'est une impression en fait vous voyez
moi il ya quelques temps je n'ai pas
bien du tout et maintenant ça y est
c'est un beaucoup mieux on profite moins
roulé par hamid unis à taux zéro parce
que bon je suis un petit peu timide je
suis heureux je suis toujours une
réserve
je réserve sur réservé je veux pas
montrer de ce que chine vous pas voilà
bon je dis allez je le faire aller tagro
qui a été fait et puis ce qui fait que
je fais et puis bon j'ai fait plus une
huile directement puis moi c'était suis
rentré dans le but c'était c'est facile
je suis très facile à rentrer je suis
rentré dedans je me suis mis dans ma
position et puis j'ai dit à leurs très
bien tu fais ton rôle est contaminée moi
j'étais parti pour faire un film c'est
pas tu vois ça tu es parti pour cent le
film donc lui pas passé dans l'acte et
unique était fascinant mais vous dans
une version complète ya plus de jeu et
cette scène avec cette structure là il
est toujours pas s'il se rendait compte
aussi c'est moi par un parent anxiété
naturel qui nous commencions à inquiéter
je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette voie quand même normalement tout
exploser un peu la gueule quelque part
mais et c'est vrai que s'il n'y a pas ça
ben c'est faux ça ne perturbe pas cette
aiguille on passe à te fais pas posé de
questions 7c des granulés pour les pour
les cochons c'est comme un crayon de
papier qui bien tailler leur cinéma très
bien payé et c'est qu'un client de
papier et toute leur vie ne voudront
qu'un crayon de papier piloter
bienbienbien piquant c'est bien petit
ping et on voit dans la vie on va dire
par exemple qu'en soirée beaucoup plus
qu'engagé malin et on va dire comme
toujours les premiers films parce que
moi j'estime c'est le premier typhon à
le train va dire il assez space 2 2
c'est leur premier ensemble de légèreté
du premier film d'insouciance mais non
ça va on sait qu'ils savent faire des
films à lindre maintenant il va falloir
qu'ils choisissent entre le fûmes
insouciant
qui ne soit pas trop mal acquis soit
juste qu'il soit voilà donc moi je pense
qu'il est une évolution et qu'ils
apprennent voilà ils vont devoir prendre
leur responsabilités après ceux d'il
faut faire d'autres pas se réfugier dans
une poésie qui devient presque
académique ce que j'ai dit est faux
attention pas tomber dans le film de
bobo c'est à dire les nouveaux films
libertaire alors continue il faut faire
attention mais ça je l'aurais johnny
d'ailleurs ils ont quand même été dormir
dans un hôtel plus à cannes se sentant
un peu coupable quand même d'être dans
un festival qui n'a rien de tu vois
c'est un peu je dis si on fait un vrai
film libertaire où l'eau fait quoi elle
est pas dans un grand hôtel là dessus
donc à lutter dormir dans un taudis de
manière à ce que je trouve quand même
assez courageux de leur part
alors que nous les acteurs n'avons
jamais prétendu à faire quelques films
divers tels que ça puisqu'on est pays
comme dit m
[Musique]
mais
le
un cadre le prends comme un jeu aussi un
peu on est comme on est super fiers d'y
être c'est le plus beau festival du
monde à des films incroyables donc
tenter d'en sélection de cannes tu es
super fier en dix ans le film grand soir
c'est seulement on ait pris un peu bon
c'est un film sur les punks à chien tout
ça donc on avait commencé un peu dans la
déconnade ont saigné là il faut faut
montrer que le film est aussi sérieux
que ça à bord des thèmes sérieux
d'ailleurs le film dure que hughes et
ont pris part donc on sait d'où là on a
calmé le jeu on va à cannes on va là
dans l'obs il dans ses cahiers du cinéma
et voilà et puis il se trouve que bon
voilà
les événements font que bon tu fais le
con puis après tu fais encore plus me
compoint faute content de faire un pont
puis et puis et puis ça vient un peu de
vie a quand même parce que comme tout le
monde se rend plus libre dans mon effet
ce que tu dirais moi ça vient pas de vie
je pense que j'ai un énorme fou rire
avec avec les deux ans dorment âme de
tournage sont capables de tout c'est ça
que j'aime bien vécu c'est qu'une soirée
commence c'est vrai les vrais sauvages
qui sait pas comment ça va se terminer
et c'est ça qui m'excite encore trahi
pas ça j'aime bien que ce soit du cinéma
ou pas du cinéma dans la vie pour moi
ils sont aussi riches quelle image
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire parce
qu'ils ont encore tellement de trucs qui
n'ont pas réussi encore à filmer mois
exprimés et que voilà j'espère qu'ils le
fassent avant de perdre la mémoire
[Musique]
à
m
rien ne change
[Musique]
g
le
est ce un coup
[Musique]
cette comédie musicale un jour on y
pense on commence à prendre des cours de
chant sera peut-être des lendemains qui
chantent